hello citizens of the reject Nation we
are going to watch Andor episode 4 today
John how are you too
sorry I mean I'm good how are you oh
yeah yeah I don't know what the hell you
were sorry about that guys I'm excited
for this usually the most watched Star
Wars show ever to have ever existed but
yeah if you can leave a like that would
be very much appreciated also subscribe
and click that notification Bell to get
notified what a reaction for episode 5
is up the Empire is so
[Music]
available for our super sexy rejects
that are patreon page along with a bunch
of other shows that we cover exclusively
from the team of prepper you guys are
all right
let's get to it
either I drop you somewhere and you
start running
will you come with me and help with
something important and of course you
could try and kill me and take the ship
option C I fought in meme but when I was
16. two years of it straight out of
prison into the mud I'm one of 50 that
survive and who did it turn out we were
fighting ourselves
so please you were on the ground in
mimbin for six months you came in as a
cook
said I know you I know the outside I
know what people tell me when I ask I
know your hatred I didn't risk my ass
for the star path unit I came for you
that was a McGuffin
what would we be stealing the quarterly
payroll for an entire Imperial site
this guy is always going to be tasked to
steal documents
that's how you become an intelligence
officer a stolen Imperial starpath unit
was recovered at the scene those
responsible unknown sir oh [ __ ] she's
open elaborate on these added protection
requests for traffic to the Abram sector
she's on the good team yeah
just gotta keep her cool too wound up
oh my girl
[Music]
think of a name for yourself
asean kandor
for the next five days you'll be clapped
I like the beard yeah bring it back it's
a karate Signet Luke kyber skystone
doesn't take less than 50 000 for it
just know it will always be worth more
to me I want it back when this is over
against two hundred thousand giving you
my word
beautiful
you want one of those
it's very Lord of the Rings feel to hurt
let's go Galadriel they built this whole
Mountain for this show today
rebellion and now you've got a mercenary
on board
I heard that take him in and lie about
how it's come to pass you plug him in as
a replacement for anyone who goes down
along the way in the next three days if
for any reason look at me oh
you've got three days something feels
off something turns someone starts to
fold you step up you lead you cancel the
mission
and if he's the problem
that's the advantage of renting him
he's disposable
the Aaron Sorkin episode yeah
lamb
[Music]
it's hot right hotter than you thought
huh but you regret trying to reject them
now you will leave here and be escorted
with haste to the transfer center where
you'll be issued with any personal items
that the imperial inspectors have had
time to inventory oh man take
solicitness you will not be replaced
you've rung the final Bell on corporate
Independence as of this morning oh god
wow
is your arm something I need to worry
about no well it's a long walk through
the night he'll walk with his legs if I
must he told me you were the boss and
you wouldn't like my being here he is
something we will never discuss when we
get to Camp we're going to tell them
this was my idea and we've been planning
it all the while we never mention him
don't talk about my father yeah he told
me about the payroll not the Garrison I
don't know who you're talking about
and taking on an imperial Armory are you
not joining us us how many of us are
there now we are seven the seven seven
against the Garrison save your wind this
is a long walk
hey hold on hold on
Oh Tie fighters
they won't be back today
it's such a well Shot Show
[Music]
would you [ __ ] me I'd be
[Laughter]
it's tuck it in my guy
[Music]
wow that's a great wig amazing wig
accomplished makeup artist depending on
the character I want the full FedEx
report it's my sector an Imperial Star
Pass unit was stolen from the steer
guard Naval Yard and found at the scene
that gives me jurisdictional access
you've been here what just over a year
you might want to steady the ladder
before you start climbing I'm not
looking for career advice you're what a
woman fool here you fool alone are you
denying my request
for the second time today fine I'll take
it to Major podcast Don't Look Down
laughs
you better think what you're going to
say because she's coming down now
she'll be coming around the mountain
when she comes
there's two they'll be here in about one
hour
[Music]
devil goats live deliciously
you know if you take your hood off
you'll look more presentable more
welcoming
yeah not like some kind of hoodlum he'll
give us critical redundancy in all areas
it's a good name for surprises that
scheme nemec
and Center
it's hard isn't it
can I speak with you let's get Clem
settled in
good to have you Clem well they call the
help we can get
so there's a team player he's definitely
dead
these Star Wars airports look so
stretched
yeah I wonder what the security
Protocols are like
oh my goodness wow
I was not expecting this very realistic
touch I know damn
senator's here finally we're waiting
what a pleasure to see you as well Luke
and sorry to be so late it's always
right when you're leaving everyone
remembers all the things they meant to
bother you with
you see the ceremonial Variety in many
places but this is the real thing it's a
unique gift for most but
it's a treasure for the true Aficionado
break down thumbnails for everyone Arrow
I'm trying to expand parents taste
Beyond fighting implements is there
anything else that might interest
I have something very special that just
came in in the back talk for real now
fourteen thousand years old sun goddess
and a serpent from the Overworld sharing
the same mouth
if you can't deliver I need to know do
you think I'm not trying I never think
that but I need to start planning if
you're no longer coming through for it I
found someone I think can help me
someone who
to bring into the circle Senator we need
funding not more people to worry about
don't touch me on vulnerability no one's
more at risk than I am you think I
haven't thought this through
I'd be the first one to fool money where
your mouth is it's a daring choice I
trust you'll have the courage to turn
back it should be a bit much I
appreciate that you'll be here are they
still talking about the lie or now this
is all about artifacts we've been
mapping the old trail for him but
that'll stop tomorrow I'm pushing all
our attention toward the loaders how
long do we have here
I've got a midnight inspection let's get
going
I love the contrasts in this episode
from like
Bonsai Bonsai
dinner for the governor poor governor
the governor of Hannah
my regimental mate that Governor that's
tonight
it's on your calendar I added it a month
ago after we discussed it
who else is coming season chances there
bars Danger slymore from the vizier's
private chamber Vader Palpatine because
these people hate me they spend every
day trying to undo anything I've touched
well perhaps tomorrow they'll think
twice
not right now please go
doing this for you don't seat them near
me oh I've taken care of that you're at
the boring end of the table these people
are fun
we should find some Gorman guests for
tonight and see how amused they are your
fun friends just cut off their shipping
lanes yesterday don't do this again
it's going back
must everything be boring and sad
[Laughter]
go to space counseling it's a suicide
run
that's why they only keep a 40-man
regiment in the Garrison because they
know no one's stupid enough to try it no
one but us
put them to the tests the old danis
Gather in this Valley for a Celestial
event they call makani breidani the eye
of aldani it hug for weeks to get here
just to see it from the sacred land to
see what imagine 50 meteor showers all
at once cool until the eye the window to
the Galaxy forms over the horizon you've
seen this I've been here almost seven
years I've seen it twice sounds
beautiful it's not the event it used to
be they've got everyone relocated it's a
pretty sad Affair but sounds pretty
corporate it's a recurrent band of
crystallized not to lose a micro
densities billions of crystals very
heavy but small and unstable as the
planet passes through the belt they
swarm the atmosphere heat up and explode
you're taking the Wonder out of it man
Beauty English this guy is chaos
that's where you gotta go into the chaos
they won't know where we came from and
if we can beat the clock we'll be gone
before they even know what happened
now you've got a lot to learn and very
little time to do it so what we need to
know is
are you in all the way let's get to it
I'm seeing signs of coordinated activity
over a number of sectors what activity
similar items of Interest repeated
methods gut instincts you came to us
from enforcement yes sir here we are
converted and verified information
bureaucracy let me when this
materializes into something more
definite until then can find Future
activities to your sectors thank you
lieutenant
I had a little smirk it's like when a
street detective joins the FBI exactly
positive note I was impressed with your
detention numbers from Sev talk far
above the quote
and maybe sending more of that sort of
work your way thank you sir we're done
let's imprison some people the actors in
this show are so good I know
like everyone
Mr Roanoke freighter specs and the
console layout you get dumbled up it's a
detailed map for the Garrison that's an
aldani phrase book
they're going to teach them how to say
something stupid can I eat my food
you'll eat you'll let sin to check the
bandage
and you'll have learned all that by
morning I'll take the First Watch
[Music]
this guy's just so not interested I know
Susanna White
and Dan Gilroy on the script all right
another solid development in the Andor
Adventures
very very great stuff I'm liking the way
it's all being fleshed out because you
got a good sense of it with Cyril but
then here with the ISP officers
it's like at this point in in the
timeline they're exploring when you know
the Empire was
just a new form of Law and Order um you
know a new form of government and you
got people who respect government you
got people who respect uh rankings and
stuff so yeah I just want to climb the
ranking I wanna I got to do my best yeah
I gotta play the game it's like
people in all parts of the world when it
comes to serving their country you know
serving their government
that it's not they're not even really
getting caught up in is this right or
wrong you're just you gotta do serve
Justice and you got to do what's best
and you gotta you gotta work your way up
the corporate ladder yeah and you trust
the words coming from above you that
that's the right you know method to go
about yeah yeah and I I didn't quite
because obviously there was no real
Rebellion yet
um and I didn't I wasn't sure how far
along we were in the and uh and the
origins of the Rebellion you know
because I'm sure there's other people
who don't like the Empire and but this
is the a very forceful one that they're
proactive one they're working on and to
see how it just this is just one tiny
unit who has to pull this off like I
like Rogue one with you're focusing on a
small group of people but the rebellions
already they're already going Toe to Toe
with the Empire you know like yeah
smaller numbers but they're already
established as the rebellion and here
you don't even have that established so
I love that that tense scene when
they're like I believe that there's a
rebellion that's about to start yeah and
I've been able to coordinate these all
together you know it's it's interesting
because Tony Gilroy you know is the way
he's always talked about this show is
like he's always just wanted to do his
own thing and not really worry about you
know Easter eggs and connecting this is
Star Wars like two uh like the the
timeline and filling in gaps and all
those things yeah
and yet it really is it's doing all of
that and stronger than a lot of these
other ones instead of just Nostalgia
winks and there we gotta reference this
or we gotta fill this in it it actually
is is a very fascinating detail
exploration of it all
and
uh that is also enveloped in a very
character-driven narrative that's very
tense and like the the dialogue of this
like that Dan Gilroy wrote this one and
the dialogue of this I thought was great
there was such a great Rhythm and
suspicion and debates happening like
with with everyone in a very reclusive
uh form of Cyril who or his whole
identity has just been stripped from him
everything he's ever worked for and so I
want to see more of that and yeah I just
love all the human touches even like
mothma
um getting to see her husband and the
friction in their relationship uh as I
know like joke around and stuff but you
know there's they keep talking so it's
usually just one lines that we have to
spew out a lot of time and uh her her
character and established like it's
always been
always been told she's important but we
haven't really gotten time to really
germinate and why she's so integral and
important unless you like want to read
further and and read like in terms of
the live action medium you really get
this opportunity now to see that
there's it's probably a clash of
ideologies with her personal life you
know it's gonna sacrifice uh a
relationship with what seems like a
great husband you really a catch a
really supportive guy didn't seem
pompous at all or passive aggressive or
anything like that yeah yeah so I I
really really love what they're doing
and I love the the secrecy
um tone that that's always here you know
like you never know who's watching you
never know who's a traitor yeah new
driver loses suspicious yeah yeah like
the whole Camp it doesn't it's not hope
is here it's
everyone's and then she has to lie to
her people yeah uh it's it's really well
really well fleshed out and and like to
put up that whole Act
that
Lutheran has to do
just for like a few seconds I love that
contrast where he comes out and he's
like so erudite and so fluid and happy
and yeah it's all just hey Mom hey I got
so many things to show you guys
artifacts oh my God is that a new
necklace oh my goodness I've got an even
better one to show you you want to see
some War implements go to the back
where's my money yeah well yeah it's
like it's it's funny in a way but it's
also like so real because it's like yeah
you you only have like a small amount of
time you've got this driver to worry
about you've got one person to distract
him so we gotta make this quick and we
gotta make it yeah like I love
that you can really feel both the
personal tension and cost for everybody
like everyone's in a really risky
position everyone's really sticking
their neck out like yeah it's it's about
the The Hope way down the line at the
moment is what I get from this show
because right now everything's a little
grungy and a little desolate the Empire
is certainly you know in control it
seems like and I love the little details
about that when uh Cassian as Clem gets
to you know the the base of the Rebel
this little Rebellion group and they're
explaining about yeah these are the
people who used to live here and the
Empire moved in they discovered
resources here so they created this Dam
and they pushed them all out and then
they you know co-opted them into their
you know uh corporate Villages and
things like that and have them you know
working and everything and it's you know
it's derived from real conquest and real
history that way and so it feels
palpable while also having you know the
Wonder of the Star Wars is Aesthetics
surrounding it but no matter who you cut
to in this episode yeah everybody is in
a desperate position and in a position
where they really have to give just the
right information no more no less and
it's a really tense spot to watch as all
these characters sort of wriggle and I
liked the introduction of the group like
I feel like in the next episode we'll
probably get you know at least to bond
to them more or to feel kind of that
team dynamic as they carry out the
mission if in fact we go those three
days are all gonna die I wonder every
every season every episode is a new team
and they all die that's the show it's an
anthology of ensembles keep remaking
Rogue one that's right yep that's what
you get to steal these papers we gotta
upload it to the Rebellion all right now
we're stealing something we're stealing
some payroll we're stealing some money
here was let's let's do that hey there's
a little Cassian made it out at least
yeah I hope some of them live because at
least a couple of them are actors that I
feel like you would have around for a
little while but yeah just like the
perspectives you said Aaron Sorkin and
and I mean Tony Gilroy and Dan Gilroy
certainly write these very
thick and dense and very well-informed
pieces whether they be informed by
something social or something more
bureaucratic but like both of those
strengths I feel like are at play here
because there is so much that is in like
political tension and just the chess
game of information and Intel and even
like it's fascinating the way they
portray the Empire characters in this
show I mean aside from like Cyril and
the crew being completely dressed down
and the Imperial officer basically being
like yeah we're just gonna put all our
own people in there your whole unit is
pretty much done now and even watching
just like the tensions back and forth
between
um
um blanking on her name right now blonde
lady uh uh
ISP officer blonde ISB officer uh she
like I said I love wondering about a
character like that because part of me
is like she seems like she could be
really intent on this on her
jurisdiction and and you know finding
out these disparate threads of rebellion
that she's noticing and and unraveling
them or she could be hiding in plain
sight you know and I I like you know
that question mark and they've again
like across the board like the casting
is so great like everyone thus far no
matter how small the role has has left
some kind of impact
it's a good uh it's a good uh ensemble
no I didn't disagree more I hate them I
hate them
recast the show halfway through
yeah I I agree with everything you're
saying John
and uh it's it's also beautiful it's a
beautiful beautiful show at the same
time all those mountains and valleys
they built I'm bummed for the show
why
because
it's a reportedly not doing as strong as
people hoped
I mean look anytime a new Star Wars show
comes out there's always a portion of
the fan base that's screaming about why
this show sucks and why is tanking and
dying yeah every time even even the big
ones there's so is someone saying that
and and this one I I think is getting
affected by that because I I do think
that I don't even know exactly why and
nor do I really want to I have like my I
have I have a bunch of theories as to
why perhaps this show is not the one
that piqued the most interest for people
maybe did not seem like maybe could have
seemed repetitive but
um but it's to me this is so different
and so mature and this is the adult
version of star like they they've
finally they've given it to us
the most childish thing that's happened
here is when that animal peed on the
Droid in the first episode yeah other
than that it's it's been very mature
and
I I love the interpersonal minglings and
and this is you know like I I have heard
people complain saying like this is just
slow
and boring nothing's happening yeah and
I'm like right well it is a bit of an
odd wrench to throw into the mix
when you have shows like book of Boba
Fett and you'll be one where you you
crave the balance of having some of this
in there and then your cool action and
your satisfying character returns and
all that yeah but there's always they
both those shows would have at least the
scene or moments that were like so
playing on the love of a Star Wars fan
you know for the yeah for the characters
and certain action scenes and such and
like
there's been like one action scene out
of three I know one and a half action
scenes that's four episodes yeah and I
don't I like I really don't mind that
and I'm watching this and I'm like man I
really like the way this show is handled
and I feel like Star Wars is especially
since Disney took it
like Rogue one has arguably been the
most mature of them all
uh however there is a sort of this like
family-friendly box that's been put in
and this and Star Wars generally has
been but then now for it to
to be elevated to this level that feels
more that feels so much more mature and
character driven and and about the
nuances of the moments and stuff and it
does bum me out when I'm like oh man
there's a lot of people who are who are
coming around being like that's boring
and stuff yeah and I do think it is
conditioning and the trailer is made it
look like it was just a Non-Stop Thrill
Ride too yeah for sure and I feel like
two maybe the tandem of releases maybe
isn't helping it either because if this
had come out like if this had been the
next one after Mandalorian I feel like
the conversation might be different
definitely or people would be uh just
more open in general because I feel like
now you have much more ground to have to
win back and two it's like it's funny to
me because because also there's just it
doesn't seem like this show Fosters the
same kinds of debates and it doesn't
make the same decisions as most of the
other shows have so yeah it's like all
the more kind of bummery for that or I'm
like man this if a lot of people who are
sick of Star Wars who have divorced Star
Wars you see a lot of those think pieces
you know if you give this one a shot
there are those people that who have
like I'm officially done after this one
mm-hmm
so it's a bummer but what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
um because yeah too like like I think
that was a good point is is in trying
not to kowtow and and to just Pand in
trying not to Pander to Star Wars as a
fan base and rather just taking the
elements in the situation seriously and
telling its own story within that I feel
like you do you know manage to show it
shows how you can go back to these
periods of time and justify doing so
like make it a worthwhile experience and
so yeah it's it it multiplies the bummer
yeah because I'm looking forward to
seeing how this Mission goes down and
obviously I'm not worried about like
Cassian andor's life so in a situation
like with a prequel story you do have to
make the Journey of what he's going
through like oh wow you know when you
see him in Rogue one he's like I think
he's Lieutenant by that point and he's
he's respected and obviously that it's
not just the one the rebellions on seven
people years it's obviously a lot more
people out there and uh like yeah even
Luther talks about it like I was gonna
shut you guys down because there's
there's fractions they mentioned
sagarrera so there's there's other
portions already that uh that are gonna
eventually have to come together
um but it I think it is a cool story to
see this guy who's just from the streets
of uh just a runaway
um and then now you'll see him rise to
like one of the the top military people
of the of the rebellion and one of the
most reliable people someone who will be
respected you know I think that is a you
know and watch how he changes as a
character through that but he's also
surrounded by a lot of very interesting
characters and a lot who are not
mentioned at all in other things so I'm
like damn how many of these folks gonna
die what you know every yeah every new
set of people Cassian has to link up
with is gonna die except for him
was talking about Baylor regano at one
point um probably
yeah makes a lot of sense
Easter egg yeah there you go Tony Gilroy
lied to us yeah how could he bye having
to adhere to very specific cannons in
the world that would have been bad right
man one offhand reference is all it
takes
um but yeah like the mid the way they
established the mission there is a that
Heist spy quality to it it feels like a
mission yeah you know like a real
Mission show and and underdogs and you
feel the struggle
so I'm really liking it and I hope more
people uh get on board with it because
it is really to me it's a great show and
it's it's so well fleshed out and and
everyone's just you could feel like a
heart and soul and passion on all fronts
on this one yeah it's crazy they let
them really take their time with this
one and and zoom away with some other
shows I know like Mandalorian like yeah
man do it man but go for it keep it
going everyone we're like real up and
down real weird Pace real weird pacing
I'll take a consistency of pace and tone
over over there yeah because I was like
this is more of what this is kind of
what I thought I was hoping everyone
would do in terms of uh the way the
character the way the pacing and the
tone is and how it a lot of the
character nuances in the mood and and
not in more plot you know well and it it
seems to come from the place of why are
each of these people who they are even
if we're not seeing the grand majority
of everyone's backstory like even the
Imperials feel
more human which to me is almost more
scary because you're like oh like you
must have had to have developed this
ideology or or at least had it had the
seeds of it to be helped along later and
I think there that's another thing is
yeah they're really good at showing
both angles they're good at depicting
the whole picture as to you really get a
sense intimately for who we're up
against not just the sort of oh yeah Tie
fighters and and Ur you know
totalitarianism but you really see like
the inner workings and how like even the
people in the Imperial uh you know in
the in the Security Bureau and all those
other places like how they are really
like bound and adhered and and you know
conditioned through all these situations
like it this is this fascinating like
oppressive lifestyle that so many people
choose to lead and then you know the
more ragtag ground level on the other
side and you even get moments like I
think spending so much time in pharynx
for the first three episodes was a nice
touch too because you really get a sense
for just people living
while we have this Rebellion story
Brewing that then Cassian will
eventually you know leave to go pursue
but you know you get that that like what
real people suffering during this you
know what are we really fighting for and
then it's that you know
well I think
are you you hear often the word like
goals and whys when it comes to writing
characters and uh the one other phrasing
is uh one of the best ways to get
audiences on board with characters is
find out let the audience show the
audience what they what their want is
what their wants are and I think that's
what the show does really well I mean
that was really overt in the beginning
with Cassie there's a flat out said like
I know what you're watching here's your
wants and and that's what gets you on
board with characters and and that's
what they were like that's why you feel
them even though you don't agree with
what Cyril was doing like you you know
what his wants are this ISP officer lady
you know what her wants are and you know
the the obviously the rebellion of
course you know what their wants are and
and then use the friction that uh Mata
and um and Luther were having the Battle
of of Wands and and I think this show
does a really good job at showing us
what the wants are and that's why I
think it it's it can be very gripping so
yeah the ones and the needs
all right guys well thank you for being
here and uh you can check out our
patreon page
and appreciate the support and we will
talk to y'all soon
[Music]